foreign
on Saturday August 2nd at around 9 30 PM
you vanilla was born while I do have a
daughter her name isn't you vanilla and
she wasn't born on August 2nd
this was a graffito a message written by
a proud papa or a proud mama on the
walls of ancient Pompeii nearly 2 000
years ago
and while we might send a birth
announcement or take to social media
this pompeian took to the walls to
exclaim their happy news and even
accompany the message with the drawing
of little you vanilla herself
the reason why we have this graffito and
thousands like them was the destructive
and deadly eruption of Mount Vesuvius in
79 A.D
this volcanic eruption preserved this
graffito for us today
we might wonder what happened to little
juvenile likely only a few weeks old
when the eruption happened I hope she
was able to escape with her family as
many did
I've been interested in the Romans since
I was little and Pompeii especially as I
share my birth date with the eruption of
Mount Vesuvius on August 24th
I started learning Latin in high school
and why I enjoyed the language and
enjoyed learning about the Romans I
couldn't connect with the stories of
Julius Caesar or even the love poetry of
avin
I wanted to know what were ordinary
Romans doing and thinking
and in college I was introduced to Latin
graffiti now for the first time I could
hear the thoughts and words of ordinary
Romans when I went to Pompeii I could
put myself in their sandals standing
next to a column Imagining the messages
they might write to one another
line graffiti allow us to hear the
thoughts and words of ordinary people
who lived in antiquity
but I believe by studying Roman graffiti
we can learn a lot more about what makes
us human and a lot more about ourselves
too
now when you hear the word graffiti
you're probably imagining spray painted
messages in urban centers bathroom
graffiti or maybe graffiti artists like
Banksy but Ancient Graffiti were much
different than modern graffiti modern
graffiti are typically illegal or at
least Taboo in cities today Ancient
Graffiti were welcome or even permitted
they appear in nearly every space in the
ancient city temples tombs bars public
spaces and even inside homes almost
nothing was off limits
modern graffiti are typically written in
spray paint or scratched into a surface
like a bathroom stall
Ancient Graffiti were typically
scratched into the wall posture using a
sharp instrument like a stylus or a nail
in fact our English word graffiti comes
from the Italian word meaning scratched
and was coined when 19th century
archaeologists first encountered the
scratched graffiti of Pompeii
Ancient Graffiti were written by a wide
variety of people and they're some of
our best evidence for people
marginalized from the literary record
like women in the enslaved
now the reason why the pompeians wrote
so many graffiti is they didn't have any
access to inexpensive writing tools like
paper
so they took to the walls to send
messages to one another record
observations or even record things using
tally marks in the same way we might use
scrap paper our phones or even social
media
now on the screen now are two of the
most famous graffiti from Pompeii
unfortunately both of them don't survive
for us today but drawings made at the
time of their excavation allow us to see
what they once look like
the one on the top says this is the
Labyrinth the Minotaur lives here
and is accompanied by a drawing of a
labyrinth from mythology
this graffito was written inside a
private person's home there wasn't the
same taboo about writing in personal
space like there is today
I doubt any of us would be too happy if
somebody came into our living room and
wrote a message such as this
the bottom graffiti shows us that the
pompeians themselves had a keen
awareness of how many graffiti covered
their walls it says oh whoa I'm amazed
you haven't fallen down holding up so
many scribblings
this message was repeated several times
throughout Pompeii this particular one
comes from the amphitheater which is the
space in which the Gladiators would
fight
now most graffiti and Pompeii were
scratched as I mentioned but some were
written with perishable materials like
charcoal and chalk
these graffiti are the subject of my
present research and they've been almost
totally ignored by modern scholars in
part because very few of them survived
to this day
this is a shame as these graffiti are
often more flourishing inventive and
elegant than their inscribed
counterparts it was far easier to draw
on top of the wall plaster than to
inscribe into it
now here's an example of one of these
graffiti
this one was written on one of the gates
leading out of the city
and it was likely made with chalk or
maybe even just a clot of Earth
it says Victor with fellow Terrace
everywhere
you can see the very elegant Roman
cursive in which this message was
written
can you trace the large flourishes on
the v y and R letters
the author included a playful Branch to
the right to complete the message
now just above this one was a graffito
made in charcoal this time the name
Victor with a flourishing V and right
below it a portrait maybe a Victor
himself
we can just make out the right side of
his face his eye and his nose
now I'm interested in ancient Aesthetics
what does the way the graffito was
written tell us about the person who
wrote it and their motivations
now here's a graffito you don't need to
know Latin to understand
this one was inscribed into one of the
bath houses of the city
can you read it
how about now
that's right this was originally written
upside down
now we don't know if the author wrote it
upside down while standing right side up
or if they twisted their body to write
it upside down but either way it shows
us the playfulness of so many of the
Roman graffiti
have you figured out what it says
what if I do this
this was an alphabet
it's the Latin alphabet intersperse
forwards and backwards so it starts with
a then it goes to X which is the last
letter of the Roman alphabet then B
then U which is the second to last then
C then T which is the third to last and
so on and so forth so we have the
alphabet written upside down and
interspersed forwards and backwards it
doesn't get more playful than that
and we can see a utilitarian message
such as an alphabet could even be
written with elegant writing the C and
the d letter tails are so long they
cross
for the pompeians it wasn't enough to
write on the walls they wanted to write
beautifully
now looking at graffiti and isolation
such as this is interesting but we can
gain so much more when we examine them
in context to understand how these
graffiti relate to each other and the
places they were written in
but to do that we're going to have to
travel to ancient Pompeii
now I wish we could all go there
together instead I'm going to take us
there virtually
we're going to walk down one Avenue in
ancient Pompeii to find the graffiti
that were once written there and figure
out what can these graffiti tell us
about life in Antiquity and life in the
21st century
this is our Avenue that we'll be walking
down the vicolo dominandro
a small Street in a residential district
we're one block off from the Main Avenue
in town in between the theater and the
amphitheater
as we walk down the Avenue we see many
names
most of the names are male as we believe
many more men than women were literate
in ancient Pompeii but some female names
jump out to us too
it used to be assumed that very few
women in the ancient world were literate
but graffiti from Pompeii have truly
complicated that picture
amongst all the names
we see a greeting
this greeting says Prima sends many
greetings to secundus
now Prima and secundus mean first and
second in Latin so these might be names
or they might be nicknames
so we have a message from one person to
the other well why did Prima write her
message here on the facade of the wall
plaster well partly to get her message
to secundus and to make sure the rest of
Pompeii could read it
this is the equivalent of a tweet or a
Snapchat
wall posts have been around for over two
thousand years
now we can take a look at how Prima
wrote her message
she wrote it in Roman cursive but we can
see it looks a lot different than the
charcoal and chalk examples I showed
earlier
it's difficult to inscribe into wall
plaster so some of the letter forms
become economical such as the E's which
are underlined on the slide they become
just two vertical marks
we can see though that Prima included an
interpunct a horizontally centered dot
between the first and second word and I
literally mean first and second that's
what those words mean in Latin
this interpunk helped to show where the
first word stopped and the second word
began and was a mark of elegant writing
now just below this graffito there were
several drawings unfortunately we don't
have these ones today but I've drawn
them here to show you what they might
have looked like based on other drawings
found at Pompeii
there were four boars three birds a
gladiator a ship and a partridge and a
pear tree I'm kidding about the last one
now Scholars such as Catherine Huntley
have used developmental psychology to
propose that some drawings were the work
of children
but others like these could be the work
of adults too replicating things they'd
seen or heard in picture form
my point here is that just like the urge
to write on a wall is as old as time I
believe the urge to Doodle is a feature
of the human spirit
now a little bit further down our wall
we might have a reply from secundus to
Prima again these might be nicknames so
we're not sure but it's possible this
message says secundus two greets his
Prima everywhere I ask mistress that you
love me
now let's look at the way secundus wrote
his message he didn't write it in the
Roman cursive like Prima and definitely
not like the flourishing cursive we
started with
instead he wrote his message in capital
letters so that Prima and the rest of
Pompeii wouldn't miss it
and if we look he accentuated the
message with the Box surrounding it as a
way to highlight the message and to make
it look more official Like official
inscriptions
if we look at the way secunda spelled
his words he left off the M's on most of
the words likely because they weren't
being pronounced at the time
if you've ever said gonna instead of
going to you're familiar with this sort
of phenomenon
just below this message sukundis wrote
two further greetings
unfortunately we don't have drawings of
these ones but the excavator who
discovered them said that they were
written by the same person and using the
same instrument so they probably looked
pretty similar to the message above
and these ones say secundus greets us
Prima sukunda secundus greets his Prima
can't we just feel secundus's love
through these messages
again secundus has left off the a in
spelling prima's name all three times
probably because it wasn't pronounced
I tell my Latin students don't be afraid
of making mistakes even the Romans made
them
now why did secundus and Prima write
these messages to one another Well
partly it was to get their messages to
the other person but I believe there's
something else going on here too
part of it is to take take part in this
thrill of discovery how many of us have
left a sticky note for somebody or put a
note in a lunchbox or written on
somebody's social media to find later
oh come on everybody's hand should be up
right
you want to get your message to the
other person but it's also taking part
in the thrill of Discovery knowing
you're leaving something behind for
somebody to find later and I believe
that's a motivation for these greeters
in Pompeii
now we continue down our walk and we
find more evidence of elegant writing
here we have a farewell greeting wineria
goodbye and the ends of the letters made
to look like branches
just below it is a graffito that has
stumped Scholars it doesn't really make
sense in Latin
I believe it was a first attempt for the
graffito above or perhaps somebody was
replicating the elegant graffito above
in rather simpler form and they weren't
as effective
these two graffitis show us the true
Elegance that was possible in some of
these Latin graffiti
now as we can you continue down our
Avenue we end with a graffito that shows
us a group almost completely left out of
the literary record and these are the
enslaved
this graffito says amiantos slave of
qualius caldis a clothes washer
now clothes washing was a notoriously
dirty business in Antiquity one of the
materials used to wash clothes was urine
while we wish we could know more about
amianthus's life this graffito has at
least given us the name of one of the
many enslaved whose lives have been lost
to history
we end our tour with one final graffito
this one says on September 3rd Satora
was here
how many of us have seen a graffito such
as this or such as this
but waiting at the train station or
using the restroom
zatura could hardly have known that a
destructive and deadly eruption in 79
A.D would preserve this graffito and
thereby her memory for us today
the urge to write on the wall to leave
your name behind in space and time is as
old as time
while I am by no means advocating that
we all go out and start writing graffiti
I hope we consider can consider what
messages we're leaving behind and what
we hope will last for the Next
Generation thank you
[Applause]